قالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان المنطاد
الصيني الذي رصدته الولايات المتحده مدني
يستخدم لاغراض البحث وخاصه الرصد الجوي
واضافت الوزاره ان المنطاد انحرف بعيدا عن
مساره المخطط له وان بيجين تاسفوا لدخوله
المجال الجويه الامريكيه عن غير قصد
ولاسباب خارجه عن ارادتها كما اكدت لوزاره
ان الجانب الصيني سيتواصل مع الجانب
الامريكي للتعامل بشكل صحيح مع هذا الوضع
غير المتوقع
وكانت الولايات المتحده قد اعلنت ان
المنطاد جرى تتبعه منذ دخوله الى المجال
الجوي الامريكي قبل ايام قادما على ما
يبدو من كندا وقال مسؤول امريكي ان الهدف
من المنطاد هو التجسس ومسار المنطاد يمر
فوق عدد من المواقع الحساسه لكنه اشار الى
ان تاثيره محدود في جمع المعلومات
الاستخباريه كما ذكر ان وزير الدفاع
ورئيسه هيئه الاركان المشتركه الجنرال
مارك ميلي او صايا بعدم اتخاذ اجراء
عسكريا بسبب الخطر المحتمل لحطام المنطاد
اذا سقط في مناطق ماهوله وفي كندا تحدثت
وزاره الدفاع عن حادثا ثان محتمل مرتبط
بمنتاضي تجسس صيني واشارت الى اتخاذها
تدابير لضمان امن مجالها الجوي
اذا تاتينا هذه الصور مباشره من ميريلاند
حيث يتم رصد هذا المنطاد الجانب الامريكي
يقول بانه منطاد تجسس صيني الا ان الصين
تنفي وتقول بانه مدني وانحرف عن مساره
لاسباب غير اراديه ينضم الينا من واشنطن
مراسل جزيره فادي منصور فادي هل من تعليق
من الجانب الامريكي على الموقف الصيني
الاخير بان المنطاد مدني
لكن هناك
مسالتان اساسيتان الان هناك دعوه من كبير
الجمهوريين في لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في
مجلس الشيوخ جيمرش لاداره بايدن بعمليا
الغاء زياره وزير الخارجيه الى الصين عشيه
هذه الزياره والتي كانت هناك امال كبيره
عليها في مساله استقرار العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه وهي اول زياره له لوزير
الخارجيه في اداره بايدن الى
ودعا ايضا الى اتخاذ اجراءات من قبل
الاداره من اجل ازاله هذا المنطاد من فوق
الاراضي الامريكيه لكن هناك ايضا في
المقابل انباء عن مصادر وفق تقارير
اعلاميه بان الخارجيه الامريكيه وان اداره
بايدن سوف تعلن عن ارجاء زياره وزير
الخارجيه بلينكن الى الصين كنوع من
الاحتجاج على هذا الموقف وما حصل تحديدا
قول الولايات المتحده ان هذا
الصيني هو مخصص لعمليات الرصد والمراقبه
وبانه عمليا يطير او يحلق فوق مناطق حساسه
في الولايات المتحده وان كان على علوم
مرتفع للغايه ولا يعرض الملاحه الجويه
للخطر نتوقع حقيقه خلال الساعه المقبله
موقف ما من الخارجيه الامريكيه وفق
معطياتها حتى هذه اللحظه
محظور التصريح بشانها ولكن يبدو ان هذا
الملف يتطور على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه
بالمعنى السياسي سوف ننتظر اذا كان سوف
يكون هناك تغيير في الموقف والتقييم
العسكري حتى يوم امس كان الموقف من قبل
القياده العسكريه الامريكيه بانها اوصت
بعدم استخدام خيارات عسكريه ضد هذا
المنطاد حفاظا على سلامه المواطنين
الامريكيين والممتلكات الامريكيه
هذه منصور مراسل جزيره كنت معنا من واشنطن
شكرا لك